okay let's use those two numbers how am
I going to put them in what shall I
write any takers what are you yeah
excellent
now that okay happy times there's the
factorization and I can use that
factorization to get to the next step
which is the solution that was kind of
what I wanted to do because I started
with an equation okay
U is going to equal to in this case
either negative 2 that's the solution
for here or yeah okay oh that's a good
question by the way is it and or is it
or now this is going to become probably
more important later on when we start
dealing with inequalities and that kind
of thing I'll give you the short answer
now in this context it makes sense to
say or because U is just a single number
it can't be both of these at the same
time who studies physics you never study
physics a lot of you study physics okay
well I'm not going to get into quantum
superposition because these guys are
numbers they can just be one thing at a
time
okay so therefore it's or as opposed to
and which kind of implies it's both of
them
at the same time that's a bit of a
weird-looking number okay so that's why
I'm writing or rather than and all right
am I done man
I mean it looks pretty done right cuz
I'm like cool I got to that something
equals something part but I what am i
doing yeah what's the issue very good
excellent so I did this right we did
this well you did it because I told you
to we did this we did it just to make
this easier to see and to deal with the
original question had nothing to do with
you right so if someone says to you hey
can you um can you get me can you can
you cook me like a steak and it's medium
well I'm really hungry can you tell I
want I want this right and you're like
oh I know how to do that and you you
know you go to the fridge and you get
out like all of the ingredient and you
just put them on the table you're like
but you didn't you didn't hit the that's
not what I asked for
I asked for something to do with X's and
you've given me something to do with use
you have to answer the question so I
to go back to this language of X's and
everything like that right so I'm gonna
write everything back in terms of X's
like so so I'm back in the original land
of the question are you happy with that
so far okay good
I'll leave this one one second let's
come to this guy I think we can think of
the number that you can put into there
right away and it gives you a valid
solution x equals 2 because 2 squared
does equal 4 happy times okay hello this
guy let's have a look at him what's that
number that you put in here that's a
very messy X that gives you negative 2
hmm let's try negative 1 we were trying
numbers before right so 2 to the power
of negative 1 what what do you negative
numbers mean for indices so negative
numbers mean fractions but why is that
why why does suit of negative 1 why does
it actually equal 1/2 huh what do you I
can whoa the square root of 2 so that's
another guy again the square root of 2
is to the power of 2 to the power of 1/2
not the number so now let me just pause
for a minute I don't know what you
thought of when you started out this Y
and you're like oh we're looking at
indices we learnt this in year 7 and 8
this is not that hard right it's not
that hard when you only think the
indices are this it's just completed
multiplication right that is pretty easy
because that's all there is to it but
now you see there's all these different
pieces that come in two indices if
you're feeling at the moment wait what
was the difference between all those I
thought they were all the same thing
that's a signal to you you have some
extra work on this that we're not gonna
have time to have a look at in class
because we have the rest of the
extension course to look at misses these
are not very happy to help you out
outside of class time but this is not
something we can slow down for ok this
is part of why we said extension is a
challenging course that requires mastery
of a lot of different things they wonder
does it make sense just want to make
that note for you okay now
the reason why this is a half is because
indices are repeated multiplication
right there about I'm too lazy to write
multiply multiply multiply multiply so
when you've got minus one this is the
opposite of multiplication what's what's
the opposite of multiplication its
division it's dividing right that's why
this is 1/2 right it means don't
multiply by two it means start dividing
by two in this case do it once ok so it
does x equals negative 1 does it fit for
this it doesn't tell you why wait can we
try something else can you think of
another number that will work hmm so
let's think about this as I put in
negative numbers like negative 1
negative 2 negative 3 I'm just going to
get smaller and smaller fractions and
you okay with that like 1/2 1/4 1/8 and
so on okay what do you reckon 1 over 4
so I come over here if I put fractions
in here right what you're getting is
square roots or cube roots or fourth
roots you can put this into your
calculator and test it out if you like
they're gonna be like 1.4 1.1 1.2 I'm
still not getting negative am i this is
kind of irritating guess what and we're
going to get to the graphs that I think
will convince you of this later on but
for now I don't want to get into that
thorny bramble there's no solutions in
the numbers that we know about that will
give you an answer to this you can take
your calculator and you can put any
numbers you'd like in your calculator
into this equation and you will never
get out a negative number because
indices can make numbers bigger and they
can make them smaller but they can never
make them negative unless you start it
out with an exact a good question yeah
we're gonna that's that's exactly right
you're like wait it asymptotes come from
we will come to that shortly but I don't
want to start graphing and then we get
too confused but the short answer is yes
okay
so we're almost there we have literally
one line left okay I just want to look
at this last line that we've written
here it says this
are you happy to leave our answer like
that I'm not happy because this looks
confusing to me right half of my working
says there's a solution and the other
half says there isn't so is there or not
you reckon is one solution that guy are
you sure this is a solution how could
you know like without mrs. Lee's where I
tell you how could you know where this
is solution or not ah we said it's one
of the other right it could be one or
the other in this case looks like it's
not this one that didn't give us any
solutions so in fact I'd recommend from
here you run right one last line tie it
all up in a neat bow and say therefore x
equals two only and there is a way that
you can note without me telling you in
writing in red is a way you can know
that that must be true what was the
suggestion we gave you what have you got
to the end yeah you can substitute it
back in right here's where we started
yeah let's just quickly check this out
four to the power of two is 16 take away
2 to the power of 2 plus 1 2 plus 1 is 3
so 2 to the power of 3 is 8 and then
there's on the end and minus 8 what's
this equal to it's 0 just like we were
supposed to get are you ok with that
so does check out you can always know
this is one of the best things about
algebra you never have to like rely on
check your friends answer or checking me
I mean you can but you can check your
own answer right and and it's worth
being good enough algebra to do that ok